vielen dank für die einschätzung wir
werden uns im laufe des vormittags öfter
noch sprechen und gehen jetzt aber ganz
schnell zu paul ronzheimer der seinen
standort inzwischen gewechselt hat paul
wo bist du jetzt thomas ich wollte dir
einen mitnehmen hier das ist eine ganz
normale straße eine ganz normale
situation heraus gebäude und hinter mir
seht ihr schlange dir eine autoschlange
vor einer benzin station hier vor einer
tankstelle die leute wollen flüchten so
schnell wie möglich weg aus dem gebiet
das heute morgen angegriffen wurde und
wir hören von weizen immer noch
mörserbeschuss von dieser seite diese
richtung ist die front und die menschen
waren und dort weiter weg richtung
westen bloß raus aus der ost ukraine nur
die frage ist ist das wirklich raus oder
kommt die gene von allen seiten und es
gibt kein weg vom ja was denn hier die
tankstelle hier sieht man wie viele
autos dort bereit war und immer
weitergekommen man will sich mit benzin
eindecken um hier aus der ost ukraine
von der direkten frontlinie die von
meinem standort hier nur den kilometer
ungefähr entfernt ist das wirkt so als
hätten die menschen das gestern noch gar
nicht er befürchtet dass es dann heute
nacht so wirklich richtig los geht das
ist ja auch ein zeichen dafür dass es
jetzt ganz plötzlich gekommen ist dass
die menschen jetzt erst weg wollen ja
die menschen der ost ukraine haben den
krieg er seit sieben jahren zumindest
direkt an der frontlinie aber das jetzt
verschiedene bereiche bombardiert werden
wir hören von ukrainischen quellen dass
hunderte soldaten heute morgen bei den
angriffen ums leben gekommen sein soll
wir sehen immer weitere autos die hier
kommen dass dem tatsächlich
fluchtbewegung die man hier in der
situation so noch nicht gesehen hat
sander ja und das wundert mich auch wie
man davon noch überrascht zeigen kann
dass da die nation angeklagt aber
vielleicht ist es so dass es in der
vergangenheit so viele ultimaten so
viele imminent in welchen gegeben hat
dass es möglicherweise bald losgehen
paul die meldungen sind auch wie es in
einem krieg üblich ist kommt von
verschiedenen seiten kommt verschiedene
meldungen die ukrainische armee hat nach
eigenen angaben fünf russische flugzeuge
abgeschossen werden gleichzeitig die
russische seite meldet dass die
militärische infrastruktur der
ukrainischen luftwaffenstützpunkte
zerstört worden sei das ist jetzt
natürlich auch ein propagandakrieg wie
in jeder militärischen
auseinandersetzung wie in jedem krieg
wie können sich die menschen überhaupt
informieren
das ist sehr sehr schwer man weiß nicht
so zu sagen welcher quelle man wie
glauben sollen gerade eben ist hier wie
man bei uns vorbeigekommen hat seltsam
nach unseren akkreditierungen gefragt
wir wissen nicht genau was dort passiert
dass ich muss einmal ganz kurz
nachfragen unerwünscht
[Musik]
gerade haben sie zu meinem über selbst
bei ihr gesagt sie werden ihn auch
gleich in die armee einzigen also man
sucht hier offenbar nach männern die
noch bereit sind hier in die armee zu
gehen also von polnischer seite das ist
wirklich sehen wie man sie sich nicht
vorstellen kann thomas und ich hoffe du
kannst du kannst mit dazu beitragen dass
der übersetzer bei dir bleiben kann denn
es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass wir
berichten dass der westen jetzt
westliche medien berichten was dort
wirklich passiert ok paul du erst mal
dass ihr da klar kommt vielen dank für
den moment und wir haben bilder von
aktuellen flugbewegungen aus der ukraine
die bundesregierung da sehen